[Music]
making news because her swift legal
battle is officially over
Taylor believes Taylor was present for
the welcome verdict this afternoon
it's a swift victory how's Taylor
holding up her lawyers arrived just
before 7:30 a.m. her publicist and her
brother Austin were also present in his
closing arguments today
Swift's attorney quoted Taylor's own
testimony against former radio DJ David
Mueller saying quote I am NOT going to
allow you to make me feel like this is
my fault
because it isn't Taylor claims that
David Mueller groped her at a 2013 photo
op right before this Denver concert
Mueller's lawyer representing his
closing arguments telling the jury quote
her skirt is not disturbed
I saw Taylor mouthing in response yes it
is Swift was dressed in all black today
and she became frustrated at points as
Mueller's attorney accused her of
fabricating her story she even swiveled
around in her chair so her back was
facing the jury as she appeared to
become emotional her mother Andrea was
seated right next to her Andrea also
appeared to be fighting back tears
Taylor side was already celebrating one
victory on Friday a judge dismissed all
of Mueller's claims against her saying
he didn't prove that Taylor got him
fired when her team reported her
allegations of assault to his former
bosses just before lunch the jury was
handed the case six women and two men
voted unanimously that Mueller did in
fact grope Taylor for her counter suit
Taylor was awarded just one dollar and
amount she sued for because she said she
was trying to prove a point and quote
serve as an example to other women
Taylor's mom Andrea cried as the verdict
came down Taylor also teared up and she
quietly mouths thank you to the jury
[Music]